let's talk about kinetic energy
calling kinetic energy K and it's given
by one-half MV squared and this is a
scalar quantity so it's going to be
either zero or positive it's never going
to be negative yeah yes I unit for
kinetic energy is Joule so we have one
Joule here for kinetic energy and the
units come from this we have kilogram
and meter per second squared now let's
assume we have an object that is first
at rest and then it speeds up with a
certain velocity you know which means
the object is going to experience a
change in kinetic energy and so we'll
express this as one-half and the final
squared minus one-half M V initial
squared and if we have a motion so
velocity in in let's say a 2d or a 3d
space then we can then we have to
consider all these components here and
we can also pull out the one-half m and
then we have V X final squared plus the
Y final squared plus V Z final squared
and then minus all the initial values X
initial Y initial and Z initial now am
when we consider just a point particle
then we can also ask what is the
momentum how can we pair up momentum and
kinetic energy so I'm writing it again
here K equals one-half MV squared if we
multiply this by M upstairs and
downstairs we're going to have M m
squared over V squared and that's a
GP squared remember P equals MV and so
we're going to get that this actually
can be expressed as P squared over 2m
and so that is the kinetic energy
expressed in terms of the momentum of a
particle